Nancy's with us in Kansas City hi Nancy
how are you I'm doing great thank you so
much for taking my call
sure had a question regarding used cars
and I'd like your advice please on
looking for and selecting and what
criteria you use for selecting a used
car okay well it what price range 8,000
okay all right well what I'm going to do
is do some reading maybe some consumer
reports or something like that if I know
absolutely nothing about cars and and
say okay I'm looking at this particular
car does it have a good track record for
repairs as a general rule does it does a
Jeep Grand Cherokee does a Ford Taurus
does a Chevy Cavalier does a Honda
Accord have a good track record and you
can find a little charts of the ones
that cost more than ones it cost less
that kind of thing
to as a track record on repairs that's
thing one thing too is I'm really going
to study two or three different websites
I'm going to start with KBB Kelley Blue
Book comm and I'm going to study what
the car is worth and what they're
selling for I probably jump on stuff
like traders dot-com and see some actual
used cars that are for sale see how that
matches up with what Kelly Blue Book
says they're worth measured against that
start to get to know the market in other
words mm-hmm
and because I really want to know what
they're worth what the price is worth in
the on these things is that what the
value is versus the price and then
lastly I'm not going to do this because
I'm more of a car junkie but you might
or I might advise somebody who's not a
car person meaning they've never turned
a wrench they don't know much about
mechanics or mileage or that kind of
thing having to have a car mechanic that
you trust though that you can take the
car to and for you know 20 to 50 bucks
we'll go over it for you
you might even pay to have the oil
changed by your mechanic because they
can tell sometimes if there's junk in
the oil it's an indicator maybe
the engines got issues right okay if it
for instance had a little bit of metal
shavings in there we got something going
on in this engine or if it's a you know
hasn't been changed in a long time or
it's burnt of the oil meaning a good
mechanic can just look at and feel the
oil and tell some things about that you
could do a detailed analysis on the oil
some people do that stuff I I probably
wouldn't go that far but a mechanic can
go okay this one's going to need brakes
the shocks are bowed out on it it's a
good car but it's been it's got some you
know it's been rode hard so you know
you're going to have this in this it's
you know you got some belts and some
hoses in here that are pretty bad and
you can expect to fix those things but
overall it's a pretty good car but
you're going to have these repairs they
can tell you stuff like that kinda like
having a house inspection done before
you buy a house right that's exactly
right
yeah and so those three things are what
I would do I would look at valuation
based on the market I would have it
inspected by a good mechanic and and I
would do some studying about the
generalities of that car does that car
that that model and make of car does a
2012 Taurus have a reputation that's
good or bad overall and then that'll
tell you - if you're in the general
range
other than that I'm looking for a car I
like - so that's part of the core
program
you